that bad I don't think so okay so
you can't move out of Dallas because you
got a kid yeah I got a four-year-old we
live outside of Dallas because there's
like a better school district I wanted
my son to go to school out there I don't
want to go to school with like a bunch
of
dog ass beans you know what did he say I
haven't seen anybody take away the ER
from that word let's go to the ER it's
just harsh man yeah you got to take away
that bad I don't think so I don't think
it's that bad I don't like wet back
sounds kind of mean but even that one's
like it's still funny yeah like yeah I
don't think I think it's more funny than
me I think some are more mean than funny